hello everyone welcome back to the 1921
World Championship match between Emanuel
Lasker and force a roll capablanca we
already checked out three games if you
haven't seen them do check them out all
the links to the games will be in the
description below as well as the link to
the entire capablanca saga if you are
joining us just now so first three games
ended in a draw this is game for Lasker
again with the white pieces let's see if
he can well steal steal the first full
point of the match so Lasker opens with
D for the same he'd as he did the last
time he had white pieces with d5 c4 e6
Knight to c3 and of course we have the
Queens gambit declined but here Alaska
doesn't go for his Knight f3 and III
line you know how we discussed that
capablanca said at e3 shouldn't we play
not very principled you should bring the
Bishop into the game before closing the
the central pawn structure so here at
last cargos Bishop to g5 right away he
took a couple on cuz the device well not
not really but you know we could say he
did Bishop to e7
capablanca continues we have III now now
it's okay to play e3 with castles by
Black Knight to f3 and now Knight B to
d7 aqua Blanca is now ready at the
capture on c4 as soon as Lasker develops
the bishop first Queen to c2 still
waiting to see how ko Blanca will treat
the position and now capablanca says
that c5 is the most most played move
here but he goes for c6 it's a different
line but even today is c5 and c6 it's a
matter of choice you can play it you can
play both and here we have Bishop to d3
although Capablanca says that queenside
castle is much more energetic and can
give a a more colorful game but that
last was probably worried about him
being attacked on on the Queen side
himself even though even today a queen
said castle in this position is is
played and the White has a lot of
success with it but okay Bishop to d3
like we said Capablanca was waiting for
this move so now he can capture on c4
and force black to waste the tempo we
have Bishop captures on c4 and now
Knight to d5 a standard idea in this
opening you want to trade as many pieces
here as you can
Bishop captures Queen captures in
now we have kingside castle by Lasker
there were attempts of Knight to e4 here
if white wants to further complicate
things if you don't want to allow black
to just trade pieces but here Alaska
goes for the for the well we could say
timid a king side castle Capablanca goes
for further trades we have Knight
captures and c3b captures and now b6
preparing bishop to be seven c5 bringing
the rook into the game and so on
depending on what Lasker plays with
Bishop to d3 and here the h7 point is
under attack so how do you defend it
with g6 or with h6 I'm sure nowadays
pretty much everyone will play h6 and
this position has been reached a few
times after this game kappa blanka
alaska versus capablanca and every time
after this game h6 was played in this
position but the only game in this
position where g6 was played is this
where a couple lanka faced last quarter
so g6 is a very old move and it was
never repeated again
so now last week continues we have a
four he wants to push a five get rid of
his isolated pawn bishop to b7 and now a
five a couple blanca frees his light
square Bishop with c5 he wants to attack
Alaska a very strong center and now
probably e4 would would be played today
it seems like a very modern move but
last four one four Knights to d2 and
couple Unger says so it's a good move
it's hard to find a better one and now
he still ways to see what Capablanca of
course lack Square is not interested in
messing up his very strong center here
but Capablanca has to attack at once
again here he plays d5 he wants either
Alaska to decide what she's gonna do
with the center or he will start
capturing in the center but here there
was also a very interesting line b5 just
try and trick Alaska into capturing the
pawn and now if you capture then just
get seek after Sun before and now
doesn't really matter what you capture
it with then Queen g5 and now black wins
as the g2 point is under attack there's
the threat of checkmate but also you
can't defend the both checkmate and the
bishop on b5 here
okay after b5 we don't really have to
capture it you can just ignore it you
can play E for and then the game just
continues C for doesn't do anything for
a couple Blanca if c for then Y it just
keeps his very strong Center who's the
bishop he's going to transfer it to f3
and there's no problem here
so after night 2 D 2 with E 5 Polanco
continues attacking the center with
Bishop to e4 Bishop captures on e4 Queen
captures on e4 and now rook 88 just
developing this rook very nicely and now
comes a captures on b6 a capture Sun b6
and now rook to a 7 here alas curse
position seems to be improving and he's
gaining much more from the position he's
preparing Queen to b7
well maybe even Queen to c6 to try and
you know create some havoc in him blacks
Queen side but couple Blanca decides no
you are not playing that we will now
trade Queens he plays he captures on d4
and now he was probably expecting
captures captures and then some trades
in the center characters captures like
the e Capra's here and then maybe rookie
to moving after after the night here
but last pair decides I will not just
yet capture here first Queen to c6 he
doesn't just want to trade down into a
rush endgame and waste his white pieces
so Queen to c6 now threatening to win
material here couple on defense rook to
d8 and now seek a person before we have
C captures and now II capture Sundy for
if Knight to e4 would ideas of maybe
rook captures and Knight to f6 check it
doesn't really work because here kappa
blanka had night the b8 planned
attacking the Queen and the rook on a 7
and here you would have to tray down
into this endgame Queen captures on g6
first H captures rook captures Queen on
e7 and after this trade here you would
have this again and then game with with
equal material on the board so not
interested he played he captures on d4
and now Queen to f6 by Capablanca he's
not ready to trade you cannot capture of
course as the Queen is hanging so Queen
captures on f6 with Knight captures on
f6 and now Knight to f3 just defending
that d4 pawn we have Knight to d5 and
now rook to be won
pressuring the spawn here with f6
Koppelman canal prepares rook to f7 to
either trade rooks or to get his rook
into the game both this final would
capablanca King to f1 last pair starts
bringing his King into the game
rook to f7 and now rook beat a one with
rook dita sd7 now offering to trade
Alaska traits here and here last row
played g3 and it was in this position
the players agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to do here it's pretty much
well well it is a ronin game or as
capablanca said it in his book there was
no reasonable motive to continue such a
game as there was not very much to be
done by either player which is pretty
much similar to what I always say so I
really enjoyed that a little sentence by
Capablanca as well so this is Game four
of their 1921 World Chess Championship
match also ended in a draw so first four
games and ended in a draw not much
different from from let's say Crossan
versus Caruana or across and versus
kurakin in 2016 and 2018 so you know
even even a hundred years ago
Roach's championship matches you know it
it took him some time to get you know
things things are moving but you know
things will be moving as you will see
well yeah that's a game for I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank Tim
O'Connor Lawrence Morris hugger
affiliate Jack Bancroft and Mark O'Mara
cool offer can refer to my channel thank
you a lot really appreciate it as usual
you can check - on my previous videos
here thank all for watching and I will
see you soon
most likely would gain five of the
world's championship match if you have
any good suggestions from the Fida Grand
Prix that just started also you know do
do suggest something from that and of
course you know I will be checking for
your suggestions as usual yeah I think
you'll I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day